-I'm looking for --
-Oh!
♪ Good day, miss ♪
♪ Lookin' pretty,
lookin' lonely ♪
♪ Looks like you could
use a child ♪
♪ Or two or three ♪
♪ For a very modest fee ♪
♪ If, by any chance,
you're searchin' ♪
♪ For an urchin ♪
♪ I got your merchan...dise
right here ♪
♪ But I'll be clear,
tell you straight ♪
♪ They're not great ♪
♪ And they don't appreciate ♪
♪ They're possibly
the worst brats in town ♪
-So, you're s...elling
the orphans?
-♪ And me? ♪
♪ I'm just a woman
with needs of me own ♪
♪ Who'd like to do
some misdeeds of me own ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ With a certain someone ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hey, welcome back.
We're here at "Late Night"
with Kristin Chenoweth.
That was a clip
from "Schmigadoon!"
Before we get to "Schmigadoon!,"
I'm going to say, real quickly,
we're coming up on the
20th Anniversary of "Wicked."
Can you believe it?
-No.
[ Cheering and applause ]
No.
-This is a role,
obviously, a lot of people
still associate you with.
I mean, they associate you
with a lot of different things,
but we were talking backstage.
You only you only did "Wicked"
for nine months.
-Nine months.
-That is crazy.
-In fact, like five years ago,
I was in CVS
on like 73rd and Broadway,
and I was just doing
my own thing at 7:30,
getting all my crap.
[ Laughter ]
And the lady comes in
and she goes,
"You're -- It's half hour.
You need to get to the theater."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Oh, I'm not in a show
right now."
She goes, "Yes, you are.
You've got 'Wicked.'
You need to be
at the Gershwin, now."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Don't argue
with me, lady. I know me.
[ Laughter ]
It's been 15 years."
And now, it's 20.
I can't believe it.
-I can't believe it, either.
-And I was only 15
when I was cast.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Kidding.
-So young.
-♪ I'm kidding ♪
-Yes. So precocious at the time.
-Oh, yes.
-This is such a special show.
It's such a special cast.
But it's, you know,
it's inspired
by the musical -- this season,
by the musicals
of the '60s and '70s.
But it's like
a musical variety show
and there's nothing like it.
I mean, it feels like
from a bygone era.
-It is.
And, Seth, for me,
for my comrades --
I call them comrades.
You know, it's Alan
and Jane Krakowski
and DuBose and Dove and Jaime
and Ann Harada and all of us.
It feels like
our "Saturday Night Live."
Like it feels like
a Christopher Guest thing
that put us together.
We're allowed to do
our music theater
and sort of make fun of
and also love our milieu.
And, for me, it's the best job.
And I just --
Cinco Paul's brain --
our writer -- it must hurt.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of noodles
in there.
And this year he gave --
you know, last year,
I played a very buttoned up --
I had a --
I had a five-page song
[ Cheering and applause ]
without a cut.
-Yeah. A very fast...
-Patter.
-...yeah, patter song.
-I mean, talk about sweat,
you know? This year
[ Laughter ]
the role is a hybrid
of Miss Hannigan from "Annie"
and Miss Lovett
from "Sweeney Todd."
-I mean, those are
some pretty meaty roles.
-They're very meaty.
And the singing --
he always gives me hard stuff.
I'm like, "Really?"
[ Laughter ]
But, actually, I love it.
It's a challenge and everybody
just knocks it out of the park.
We think that we are very lucky
to be doing what we love to do
on camera.
-It's really fun.
Anytime you see
that the people making the show
love it
and there are so many people,
obviously,
who love that world
on a granular level,
who can appreciate exactly
what the references are.
And then there's people like me,
who just appreciate it
for a great performance,
which is really fun to watch.
-Thank you.
That would be like my brother,
who said, "Hey, listen,
don't take me to any more
musical theater, hey.
I love ya.
I don't like it."
[ Laughter ]
But he loves the show
because Keegan and Cecily
are like hilarious
and then we're all wacko
around them, so.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I think it shows?
Which is, even people
who do musical theater
appreciate that there are
some eyerolly tropes
about musical theater.
-We all can.
-Right.
And so this show both has
the execution of wonderful songs
that you would see
in a musical theater
and the characters who are
standing on the outside of it,
who maybe have
your brother's perspective,
which is why people
from both sides can come in
and enjoy the show.
-That's exactly right.
I mean, when he saw last season,
"You know what?
I like, you know,
I like the show."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "That's a huge
compliment, for you, isn't it?
Thank you."
[ Laughter ]
Alan -- we've talked about your
friendship with Alan Cummings.
How many years are you guys
going on,
as far as not just friends,
but collaborators?
-I want to say 26 or 27.
He knows me and I
know him real well.
In fact, I was just
on a cruise.
While it was at dock
because I don't cruise
because I have veneers.
It doesn't matter.
[ Laughter ]
And I can't -- like I can't --
I have vertigo.
And I was headlining this thing
and he was singing as well
and we just laugh and have fun.
And I think we should
all count ourselves lucky
if we have one friend
that lasts that long,
that you work with,
that you can laugh, still.
I mean, we still think
we got it.
We still think we got it.
-Well, we think so as well.
-Thank you.
-Somebody else
who still has it,
which is incredible
and worth honoring,
and you did just honor,
is Carol Burnett.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It was a special event
for Carol Burnett.
I had to double-check it.
Is it true?
Is 90 the number?
-She's 90.
-That is incredible!
Y'all, she is so much the same.
She is so
[ Snapping fingers ] sharp.
She's been a mentor of mine
for several years.
I might not want to say like 20.
And when we get together,
it's usually not
about show business.
It's usually about romance
and life and all that stuff.
And she's been there
through all the guys.
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
I shouldn't --
[ Applause ]
Oops!
-Most of those are
from Vancouver, right? Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course!
Where I left them.
[ Laughter ]
So, she has been
a great mentor to me
and she's accepted and loved me
and given me great advice.
But we did a tribute
to her 90th birthday
and all the years
in television.
And think about this --
so, I love her,
Bernadette Peters,
and Julie Andrews.
Those are my
music theater queens, right?
-Whoo!
-Here she is sitting
by her bestie, Julie,
and then I'm singing
with Bernadette.
If you want to talk
about a Mylanta moment,
[ Laughter ]
that was one.
-Now, can I ask?
In a moment like that,
can you be in the moment
and enjoy it
or are you just so terrified?
Because I feel I have
to remind myself --
not that I've had a moment
quite like that --
but were are you like,
"Oh, this will only --
I will only be able
to look back on it fondly
if it goes well"?
And you seem, so effortlessly,
to pull those off.
But do you have butterflies?
-Of course.
Not necessarily with Carol
so much, anymore,
because we have spent
so much time
and we both like Cosmos
and anyway.
[ Laughter ]
We've spent a lot.
But still Julie.
I mean --
[ As Andrews ]
♪ The hills are alive ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's why I became a singer!
-[ Laughs ]
-I love. I mean,
that's why I became a singer.
And then there's Bernadette.
So, I just always say,
"You know what?
You're of an age, now, that you
are being invited to the table
to do what you do
with the greats
and just try to be
as great as you can."
-Well, there you go.
It's certainly working out,
so far.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-Kristin Chenoweth.
[ Cheering and applause ]
New episodes of "Schmigadoon!"
are available Wednesdays
on Apple TV+.
"Carol Burnett:
90 Years of Laughter and Love"
premieres April 26th here
on NBC.
You can see Kristin there
as well.
It's available the next day
on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."